hi everyone my name is Stefan I'm the
executive producer of Wild West online
the whole team is excited for you to
take a look at some of what wwo has to
offer we'll start with a quick look at
the character creation screen where you
can choose your gender color and other
elements to customize your look when you
join the game for the first time you'll
spawn at the train station one of the
towns in this case it's Stone Creek look
around then move around and start
exploring and you'll never get lost in
the world because with the press of a
hotkey interactable locations highlight
in the viewport here we'll see a
clothing store Bank gunsmith saloon and
a newspaper bulletin board so we're
gonna check a bit out of what we've got
around us and then we're gonna decide
what to do next and let's go read the
paper so uh newspapers are a key part of
world building in WWI and we plan on
writing new ones on a regular basis to
expose more of the game's story and
highlight what's happened in the world
so some of the player actions become
part of the lore and they're not just
fun they'll also contain info about
in-game events in a clothing store you
can change clothes or buy a new outfit
so we'll go to this clothing shop right
over here and we're gonna skip looking
at the interface and instead we'll just
show you this new outfit that we got
complete with this red bandanna and
white hat so we look kind of badass
alright so now the next stop is the
slave all of the towns have saloons
which are the hubs for social activity
and Wild West online you can buy drinks
talk to NPCs to get quests gamble
against the house brawl against other
players and take part in other
recreational activities so we're gonna
look around in this saloon a little and
we're gonna head out back here check out
where there's the card game so you can
play in this load poker or roulette will
be different games and different saloons
now almost all open buildings can be
explored but if you take something from
there that doesn't belong to you its
theft in this case we're gonna go over
here and we're gonna steal this whiskey
bottle so there it is and we are gonna
take it
OOP already we just stole that whiskey
bottle but since no one saw a reputation
wasn't affected so the moral here is if
you're gonna steal don't get caught
because if your reputation gets bad
enough you might end up on the
most-wanted list and the Sheriff's
Office is where you can see the Most
Wanted Board and if you want enroll for
duty as a deputy any player can claim a
bounty so all you do is go over to the
bounty board over here click on it open
it up and now you can drag and drop the
bounties that you want to collect so
we're cleaning the bounties that we want
to go at Plex here grab a couple of
those guys all right so now we're saying
that we're gonna go ride out meet up
with my friend Mike and he and I are
gonna hunt down those bounties and try
and collect our reward
so before we go out and hunt those
bandits we're gonna go to a rest cabin
now in a rest cabin you can do a variety
of different things you can rest regain
stamina and health and you can use the
crafting desk to make things access your
stash of your reserved supplies and
change outfits like in equities day you
also can unlock the ability to fast
travel between cabins the map will show
you all the places you've unlocked fast
travel between and then you can select
where you want to go and pop on over
there so we are going to travel from
Stone Creek to this cabin mark right
over here hold eetu travel and bang here
we are and now you can see stash
clothing change crafting desks we can
rest up in here but what we're gonna do
now is we're gonna go find Mike as mike
has ridden out ahead and staked out a
campsite and located where he thinks the
first of our families are you can see
that in Wild West online there's
different environments this is a pine
forest the pine forest is completely
different from that plane Z kind of
location that we saw out around Stone
Creek and in Stone Creek and so we're
gonna march through this forest and
we're gonna look for Mike and
campsite so we could meet up and rest up
a bit more and then go to find our
bounties oh there he is Mike and I are
gonna team up to hunt this bounty
together and the bounty may very well
have his posse with him Mike wait over
there buddy good to see you Mike has set
up a campsite and a campsite is
basically a portable reusable rest cabin
some of them have all of the features of
the rest cabins and some just allow you
to say change your outfit and rest up
once we've rested up we are going to
head out and hunt our bounty and there
he is saving it we're gonna hit him down
and he's got his buddy Davenport with
him so Mike and I should be able to take
down those two guys pretty oh oh there's
a third guy
alright so Mike we're gonna go left you
go around here you flank them so you
take the left flank I'm gonna take the
right side good you come around and
we're gonna crossbar them so the first
thing I'm gonna do is sneak up on this
guy right here and I'm gonna shoot him
through his tent and he is going to be a
sad camper when the time is right okay
I'm ready
bye-bye you know Gatto Mike took down
Davenport oh crap
guys seen it just shot Mike and now it's
just me bastard [ __ ] there you are all
right got him all right so I got the
bounty I lost like but I gotta save Ian
and I got our bounty thank you everyone
for checking out the Wild West online
gameplay video please go to our website
at play WWE comm to sign up for the
Alpha visit our forums and subscribe on
social networks like Facebook and
Twitter to keep abreast of the latest
info get exclusive offers and make your
suggestions heard thanks